ich habe vor kurzem ein video gesehen in
denen jemand am flughafen aus langeweile
mal eben ein richtig schönes flugzeug
aus papier zimmert und um ehrlich zu
sein war das alleine inspiration genug
diese woche alles dafür zu geben um
zeichnen zu lernen ich werde heute ein
flugzeug ein auge einen baum und eine
antike statue zeichnen und mich komplett
sanieren dann werde ich die ganze woche
jeden tag den ganzen tag mit
verschiedensten tricks zeichnen lernen
und an tag 7 wieder ein flugzeug ein
auge ein baum und eine statue zeichnen
um herauszufinden wie gut man in nur
sieben tagen zeichnen lernen kann
dieses video wird von safe disk
unterstützt der software die steuern und
buchhaltung endlich erträglich macht
kommen wir zu unserem test ich sage
jetzt ein flugzeug und ich habe
natürlich schon mal in der schule
gezeichnet aber abgesehen davon habe
jetzt nichts wo den plan
es sieht aus wie ein daumen und dann
hier noch überall zu fenstern
wenn ihr das schon gruselig findet dann
kommen jetzt mal zum auge ja schön bunt
hier die tiere ist die hat nämlich auch
noch so musste also bei dem auge sieht
man jetzt immer dass ich mir mehr mühe
gegeben habe als ein flugzeug nice da
fehlt uns jetzt noch der baum und warum
hat tatsächlich auch schon mal jemand
versucht bezeichnet die baumkrone und
ganz wichtig bei der baumkrone müssen ja
auch schatten
wir bauen unser kind vor dass feste das
kann man nur sagen und jetzt kommt die
antike stadt wörth ellbogen die muckis
sind das wichtigste
hier kommt auch im muschel hin damit
auch schön werbe freundlich bleibt ich
finde die stadt will ist richtig gut ich
würde sagen dass auf jeden fall noch
viel luft nach oben ich bin hier
übrigens gerade im haus meiner eltern
wenn man es so nennen möchte im atelier
mein großonkel war maler und in diesem
raum befinden sich einige seiner gemälde
und bücher die er uns hinterlassen hat
sowie eine staffelei und einige öl
farben mit denen mein vater relativ
unregelmäßig malt um die sieben tage
möglichst effizient zu nutzen durch so
wie ich die bücher welche ich vorhin
angesprochen habe und das sind wirklich
viele bücher sehr viele bücher sehr
viele bücher hauptsächlich handelt es
sich um bücher zu malerei aber ich habe
da wären auch zwei zum zeichnen gefunden
als erstes geht es ans material
ich benutze dafür graphit stifter also
bleistifte mit den härtegraden b1 bis b
8 sowie fhb h1 und h2 h2 sda bei der
härteste stift welche also recht wenig
materialeinsatz papier abgibt und
dadurch ziemlich hell ist b 8 ist der
weiße stift welcher dadurch extrem viel
graphit als papier abgibt und dadurch
sehr dunkel werden kann
zusätzlich habe ich noch radiergummis
spitzer und einen zeichenblock in meiner
recherche lerne ich viel über
proportionen perspektive schattierung
und komposition bzw aufbau einer
zeichnung und beschließt er mein
training mit linienführung zu beginn
dabei mache ich einfach horizontale und
vertikale striche und versuche sie so
parallel und gerade wie möglich zu
zeichnen anschließend mache ich das
selbe mit kreisen dadurch trainiert man
einfach die präzision seiner
linienführung zeichnungen wirken erst
durch eine gute schattierung sehr
überzeugend deshalb übe ich feine
abstufungen mit meinen stiften von hell
zu dunkel zu erstellen sowie auch feine
übergänge
ihr habt bestimmt alle schon mal von
einem stillleben gehört ein stillleben
ist laut wikipedia die bildliche
darstellung von dingen des alltäglichen
lebens also habe ich mir diese tasse
ausgesucht es ist gar nicht so leicht
alle winkel und proportionen exakt aus
papier zu kopieren der mann aus dem
video am anfang hat dafür seinen stift
und daumen wir nutzt um sein motiv
maßstabgetreu aufs papier zu bringen
nachdem die form der tasse fertig ist
versuche ich sie zu spazieren und mit
graustufen dafür zu sorgen dass die
taste dreidimensional wirken und lande
am ersten tag bei diesem mehr
heute sind stillleben an der reihe
einfach weil ich sehr gerne in der lage
wäre dinge aus dem echten leben
realistisch abzubilden morgen
beschäftigt mich mit landschaften also
bergen bäumen felsen und so weiter
übermorgen studiere ich das gesicht
danach den körper und die jeweiligen der
zugehörigen proportion wenn ich von all
dem die grundlagen gelernt habe werde
ich einfach das zeichnen
worauf ich lust habe und was mich
inspiriert ich weiß es sehr zu schätzen
beim zeichnen nebenbei musik hörbücher
und podcast zu hören ich verbringen den
ganzen tag damit auf dem sofa oder am
schreibtisch den bleistift zu schwingen
und mit meinen gedanken in andere welten
zu tauchen
meine beste arbeit des tages ist wohl
das stillleben diese pflanze welche rund
drei stunden gedauert hat die
schattierung ist noch nicht perfekt aber
ich finde ich habe die umrisse der
pflanze sehr sehr gut übernommen
ich glaub mir fällt es deutlich leichter
dinge abzuzeichnen als das frei aus
meinem gedächtnis zu machen heute werden
wir zum ersten mal dinge frei aus
unserem kopf zeichnen und die muster
hinter verschiedenen elementen aus der
natur kennenlernen ich habe im internet
einige anleitungen zu wolken gefunden
zuerst zeichne ich den stamm und die
erste dann um reiße ich grob die laube
büschel die an den ersten drei ligen
beginnen das holz erst zu strukturieren
und dann zu spazieren und kürzer das
laub in die baumkrone welche
anschließend auch schockiert wird fertig
ist der baum
die maserung eines holzbrett es besteht
zum beispiel aus astlöchern rissen dem
querschnitt der jahresringe des baumes
welche manchmal sehr dünn und klar sind
und manchmal eher breit und weicht hier
geht es darum die prinzipien der
einzelnen sich oft wiederholenden muster
zu lernen und sinnvoll zu kombinieren
heute möchte ich lernen wie man
gesichter abbildet dazu muss ich lernen
wie man nasen ohren münder und augen
zeichnet aber natürlich auch wohin man
diese einzelnen sachen dann ins gesicht
einsetzt gesichter zu zeichnen ist so
ziemlich das schwierigste da wir
menschen wer hätte es gedacht experten
darin sind gesichter zu erkennen es ist
überlebenswichtig für uns gesichter
innerhalb von millisekunden zu erkennen
und kleinste änderungen und
unstimmigkeiten in den gesichtszügen
unserer mitmenschen richtig zu lesen und
zu deuten aber auch zu entscheiden ob
wir ein gesicht symmetrisch und
attraktiv finden deswegen fällt es uns
auch so leicht andere menschen
voneinander zu unterscheiden aber so
schwer einzelne tannen oder wölfl
wiederzuerkennen alles in allem bin ich
aber mit dem gesicht wirklich sehr
zufrieden und ich finde die haare kunden
das ganze nochmal schön ab die restliche
zeit beschäftige ich mich mit dem
menschlichen körper und seine
proportionen und beginne dann damit
einfach die verschiedensten dinge zu
zeichnen die mich inspirieren oder
interessieren natürlich habe ich nach
mehreren stunden zeigen am tag
irgendwann keine lust mehr und die
motivation sinkt aber wie immer muss man
sich einfach durchkämpfen wenn man etwas
lernt bild vor allem wenn man sich nur
eine woche zeit gibt heute ist der
letzte tag womit wir auch schon zum
moment kommen auf den wir alle gewartet
haben und zwar der vorher nachher
vergleich beim flugzeug ist die
messlatte zugegebenermaßen nicht
besonders gut und deswegen hab ich mich
hier auch extrem verbessert im auge war
rückblickend betrachtet die messer des
handels hoch und ich habe mir hier sehr
viel mühe gegeben und da bestimmt über
eine halbe stunde dran gezeichnet
wodurch wir hier auch einen sehr kassen
vergleich haben und unser vorher bild
einfach aussieht wie von dem
erstklässler obwohl der baum vom anfangs
test finde ich noch das beste war haben
wir den auch deutlich übertroffen vor
allem mit den sinnvolleren essen und den
deutlich weicheren stadtführungen und
auch für unsere statue muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen das ist davor einfach
aussieht wie vor dem erstklässler aber
ich muss natürlich zugeben dass obwohl
ich jetzt deutlich besser zeichnen kann
ich mir auch für die vorher bilder nicht
so viel zeit genommen habe wie für die
nachher bilder was aber auch daran liegt
dass ich aber nicht wusste was ich sonst
noch alles machen sollte
ich finde es richtig cool das experiment
das hat sich auch gelohnt aber ich freue
mich jetzt auch mal heute nicht mehr
weiter zeichnung zu müssen
dieses video wurde von safe disk
unterstützt es ist eine software mit der
selbstständige ganz einfach ihre
buchhaltung automatisieren können stadt
zahllose papiere in dickel hälfte zu
sortieren kann man diese mit der safer
step ganz einfach einzugehen oder am pc
als pdf auswählen lässt erkennt
automatisch die wichtigsten
informationen wo durch belege direkt
digitalisiert und kategorisiert werden
und außerdem auch wichtige statistiken
zu einnahmen und ausgaben erstellt
werden klickt auf den link in der video
beschreibung und self test gratis für 14
tage testen zu können
natürlich ohne zahlungsinformationen
angeben zu müssen nächsten samstag kommt
ein video in dem ich nur für einen euro
pro tag essen darf und das für eine
ganze woche also wenn ihr das nicht
verpassen möchte dann abonniert gerne
diesen kanal man dann sehen wir uns beim
nächsten mal wieder macht's gut
[Musik]